Michael Knowles on Whose program I have
appeared now wants to ban transgender
ISM this is the latest in the confused
and uh uh quite frankly
delusional delusionally obsessed
anti-trans right wing they have seized
on the idea
that they are going to get attention by
just being obsessed about trans and Matt
Walsh is essentially just known for
being anti-trans and he's gotten great
um publicity from it and great attention
and so now a lot of these other
right-wing Hangers On are uh trying to
mirror that and saying you know if I
just talk about trans people all the
time I'm going to get attention and
right Wingers who don't know any better
will will contribute and it'll be great
and they'll make money from it so here
is Michael Knowles and his new thing is
we just need to ban transgenderism ban
it speaking of the law as a teacher yeah
great new law in Kansas
Kansas has become the first state to
pass by the way what is it about like
the tapping of the paper that is so
pompous and pretentious I don't know
what it is about that I'll play it for
you again great do you not a great new
law there Taps the paper something about
that is just really annoying speaking of
the law as a teacher
great new law in Kansas
spiffy Kansas has become the first state
to pass a bill that defines women as
someone who is biologically born female
that's it that's what a woman is
which means that this will ban men
and we will ban men who identify as
transgender women from using single sex
areas designated for women it's called
the women's Bill of Rights right it was
approved by legislators 26 very powerful
civil rights proposal to 10 on Thursday
only Republican support there
and the bill defines a female as someone
quote whose biological reproductive
system is developed to produce OVA uh-oh
who's but now we're get that's going to
be a problem
developed to produce OVA while male
refers to anyone whose reproductive
system quote is developed to fertilize
the OVA of a female this is a beautiful
bill because
it doesn't just say don't trans the kids
it doesn't just say wait till eight
to introduce kids to transgenderism in
schools once they turn nine that's fine
it doesn't just say only miners can't
it's it bans transgenderism for all
practical purposes in the state for
everybody and it has to
in order for women to have the right to
have their own bathrooms you have to ban
transgenderism entirely ban it you can't
just ban it for the kids it's got to be
entirely while you're at it you should
ban racism too in order for women to be
able to have their own locker rooms at
the gym you have to ban transgenderism
entirely ban it in order to protect
businesses from having to participate in
weird businesses must be protected from
trans people occult sexual rituals like
the transgender transition you have to
ban transgenderism
entirely ban it okay as you can see
conservative it's not even uh I I
reflexively use the term conservative
but it's really extremist radical
rhetoric extremist radical right-wing
rhetoric against trans people is at
bloodthirsty levels
every how boring is it to just be a gay
man anymore and what I mean by that
tongue-in-cheek of course is
the they have moved on completely they
rarely cared about lesbians it used to
be all about trans men I'm sorry about
gay men now it is all piled on to being
in a bloodthirsty way anti-trans now of
course reasonable people would say how
do you ban transgenderism You Can't Ban
transgenderism any more than you can ban
homosexuality that being said what
they're talking about is criminalizing
specific Acts or
um behaviors or uh um Norms I guess you
would say and we know about the
horrifying history of that if we look at
that in history Beyond just sexual
orientation and gender identity now of
course there's this whole related thing
when you talk about
how you live versus what you feel and
acts versus all this stuff there's this
idea of one of the dangers of
transgenderism is people might fake
being trans either so they can get into
the women's bathroom and then photograph
or whatever you know things that are
already against the law
um but when you zoom out and you look at
the level of bloodthirsty viciousness
against the trans Community right now
why on Earth would anyone fake being
trans given how horribly trans people
are being treated and the level of
stigma against them now you know I'm
right there with you in saying might
someone
experiencing Strife in their life
wrongly come to believe for a period
that being in the wrong uh gendered body
um is what's causing them the problem
and then those people might explore that
and then go oh you know what this wasn't
the issue actually the issue is
something else and they moved Beyond it
sure right Wingers love to talk about it
and say you know there's all these
people who they they come out as trans
but then they go back to living uh uh as
the same gender that they were
um that matches their uh genitalia I
think is the way they like to say it
okay fine right I mean so so like
somebody might wrongly for whatever
reason think maybe this is the issue and
then it's not but the idea of the people
faking being Trans in order to do all of
these devious things like get into
bathrooms everybody wants to get into
bathrooms and locker rooms it's absurd
now of course with the whole Banning
thing
the way this is defined what happens if
a woman's reproductive organs were not
properly developed by this definition it
sounds like that she's not a woman oh
well that's an exception what if you're
born intersex oh well that's also an
exception oh so we have exceptions what
makes those exceptions any more
legitimate than those who have been
diagnosed with gender dysphoria it's
just at that point it's just arbitrary
and um we saw a similar thing when the
gun control debate was about well you
should just be able to have all arms
oh well like what about a shoulder
mounted RPG or well no not that oh so
you are okay Drawing the Line and making
exceptions so now it's just a question
of which exceptions do you consider
valid versus which ones do I consider
valid and many of these right-wing
arguments go down that path so
disgusting stuff from Michael Knowles
not surprising will have all of these
clips on our YouTube channel at
youtube.com the davidpackman show make
sure you were subscribed to the channel
folks please we just closed out February
February or February I don't care okay
however you want to say it more than
three million people who are not
subscribed to the YouTube channel
watched our videos
to you folks hit the Subscribe button it
won't hurt you in any way it won't bite
you it won't do anything to you other
than affirm to YouTube that you like
what we're doing and then they'll
recommend our content to more people
that's youtube.com slash the David
Pacman show